if you had to create a human what would
you put them through to make them tough
it wouldn't be a really chill life what
would you put them through to make them
patient well you probably wouldn't give
them things immediately and so it's like
we want these trades but each of the
traits has a price tag attached to it
it's just like do you want to pay the
price tag to get the thing and so I
think if if people reframe the period of
life that they're going through as the
price that they're paying out of their
wallet but the wallet is their time it's
the seconds of life that they're trading
for it then I think more people be
willing to make the trade because at
least when I look at myself when I'm 80
something years old and I'm looking back
on my life I want to have these traits
but in order to have those traits I know
I have to go through these things and I
think for me that's given me a lot of
comfort in hard times